what's up wisecrack jared again so Game
of Thrones is over if you're one of
those people who smugly reminds every
person you know that you don't watch
Game of Thrones you might have missed
the part where one and a half million
people signed a petition to get season
eight remade with quote competent
writers people hate this finale and yeah
fans complained about the office when
Michael Scott left or how Dexter
concluded or the whole Sopranos thing
but the Rage Against Game of Thrones
seems to transcend all barriers it has
truly United the fractured American
public after 73 plus hours of prophecy
statecraft
death magic more death and zombies we
were given an ending that felt rushed
poorly executed and possibly dumb but
unlike Twitter we want to give the show
its fair shot after all we even tried to
see the light in things like this I
don't like sand or this endings by their
very nature solidify the themes of the
show and color the meaning of every
episode that came before it so now that
we have an ending to this milestone in
television it's time to ask what is Game
of Thrones about and is it deep or dumb
welcome to this wisecrack edition on the
Game of Thrones finale deep or dumb and
obviously spoilers ahead
but before we get to it I want to give a
shout out to our sponsors over at
Skillshare the online learning community
we're all about lifelong learning here
wisecrack so having over 25,000 classes
at our fingertips has been really
rewarding there are so many different
courses to choose from one I found
particularly useful was the writers
toolkit six steps to successful writing
habit something I focused on that I took
to heart was the medium I get way too
distracted when I'm working through
early drafts on a computer so I switched
to a notepad and now I'm way more
productive that applies to all kinds of
writing but there are even courses
specifically about making internet
content whether you want to do what we
do and make video essays or create blogs
Skillshare can guide you on your journey
to build an audience so get two months
for free by clicking the link in the
description and now back to the show
first an insanely basic overview of the
show is in order
Game of Thrones is about the literal
game for the throne in the wake of the
King's death the Seven Kingdoms are
thrown into chaos as competing factions
Duke it out for supremacy also a woman
gets dragons she burns all her enemies
and finally wins that game but it turns
out the real reward wasn't the friends
she made along the way she gets replaced
by the NSA I mean bran who can spy on
you at any time with his magic in the
end to figure out whether this ending
had some greater message or maybe was
just awful we'll be looking at two
critical elements of the show its
political world building and its
relationship to the fantasy genre part 1
breaking the wheel now that we loosely
understand what happens in the show we
have to figure out what is it trying to
say one big indicator that the events of
the show have translated into meaningful
change for the realm is the big
expensive visual metaphor in which the
dragon melts the Iron Throne certainly
the wheel has been broken Ben right well
let's find out throughout the show we
see the way common people suffer amongst
the drama of the well-to-do lords and
ladies of the land perhaps no character
focuses on this travesty more than
Daenerys Targaryen mother of dragons
breaker of chains and by the end
homicidal maniac Dany has been saying
for years that she means to break the
wheel of the Great Houses of the Seven
Kingdoms Lannister Targaryen Baratheon
stir
Tyrel they're all just spokes on a wheel
this one's on tops and that one's on top
and on and on it spins crushing those on
the ground it's a beautiful dream
stopping the wheel you're not the first
person who's ever dreamt it I'm not
going to stop the wheel I'm going to
break the wheel Danny's an interesting
character because while she often had
the best intentions her plans often have
terrible consequences in season 4 she
crucified over 100 masters in slavers
Bay as justice for their crucifixion of
slave children later in the season she
learns that some of those crucified
masters fought to prevent the deaths of
those slave children your father
crucified innocent children my father
spoke out against crucifying those
children after she liberated a stupor it
was overtaken by a new tyrant because
she hadn't actually taken a time to
solidify a new political system before
moving on to the next city to conquer
the council you installed to rule over
the city has been overthrown by a
butcher named Cleon who's declared
himself his Imperial Majesty but even as
she gives speeches on mercy and
liberation
Daenerys also believes that she was born
to be the queen of the Seven Kingdoms
and deserves that title based on
bloodline bloodline succession is one of
the most common justifications for the
wheel-turning wars that Dany claims to
want to end whether that's the war of
the five kings or the Blackfyre
rebellion shout-out to you book fans
and worse by the second last episode
Daenerys commits some light crimes
against humanity and burns King's
Landing to the ground so what is the
show trying to say if we were to zoom in
on tenaris we might get a message like
some idealism often fails because the
world is a hot garbage fire and in the
final seasons we might see her growing
frustrations with the difficulty of
ruling dramatized to show us how an
idealist turns into a war criminal
instead she just takes a hard right turn
and her insanity is justified through
some heavy-handed foreshadowing is it
because through these shows careful
plotting of politics viewing yourself as
the savior of the world is a recipe for
tyranny maybe that's what the show was
going for but with just
Kramden speech Tyrion made post facto to
draw this connection
it seems light everywhere she goes evil
men die and we cheer for it and she
grows more powerful and more sure that
she is good and right she believes her
destiny is to build a better world for
everyone she believed that she truly
believed it wouldn't you kill whoever
stood between you and paradise that's
the best case the worst case seems to be
that madness is genetic as this clip in
the case they say every time a Targaryen
is born the Goths toss a coin and the
world holds its breath whatever they
were trying to say Daenerys did not end
up the savior nor the oppressor of the
realm
she got shanked so if she didn't break
the wheel did someone else is the wheel
still intact
and what bearing does this have on the
themes of politics ruling and leadership
if the whole point of the show is
studying the difficulties of ruling and
if we expect some sort of cathartic
conclusion at the end of any narrative
something must change we should walk
away with a takeaway one of the last
scenes of the finale we see the
remaining lords and ladies of the Great
Houses convene an account so to
determine who will lead Westeros Tyrion
still handcuffed proposes that what the
country needs is a leader with a good
story who will unite the people and lead
us into the future
he also proposes a nifty political
system to break the wheel called
oligarchy where bloodlines session will
be replaced by a dozen wealthy and
powerful families deciding each new
leader by their own messed-up internal
politics sons of Kings can be cruel and
stupid as you have no this will never to
mentis
that is the Wheelock Queen wanted to
break from now on rulers will not be
born they will be chosen on this spot
are the lords and ladies of Westeros
never mind that half the Great Council
is made up of northern families who then
immediately secede from the country the
north will remain an independent kingdom
it's the equivalent of like the southern
states swaying the u.s. election right
before they simultaneously peace out
from the Union so we'll see how that
goes so if we're judging whether or not
the wheel has truly been broken one
approach might be to weigh the possible
effects of the new oligarchy on the
small folk ostensibly the goal of
breaking the wheel is to better the
lives of the small folk the peasants who
have no noble standing Danny wanted to
free them from tyrants Varys wanted to
free them from tyrants Sansa wanted to
free the northern small folk from
tyrants and Tyrion wants to free them
from tyrants who don't have a good
elevator pitch but even his own story
schpeel isn't terribly consistent two
episodes ago he argued to Varys that
most of the millions of people in
Westeros don't care who sits on the Iron
Throne you know I will never betray the
row what he's the resum lost continent
home to millions of people most of whom
don't care who sits on the Iron Throne
millions of people many of them will die
if the wrong person sits on that throne
even with the throne itself melted by a
grieving dragon there's no indicator in
Tyrians final speech that he's actually
changed his mind about the apathy of the
people but even if most of the realm
doesn't care about brans story they'll
probably benefit from a pause and the
wars over the throne the north men
aren't the only ones we've been fighting
pretty much every great house has sent
their peasants into battle at some point
over the course of the show and a new
mechanism for the easy transition of
power between houses would have a huge
material benefit for the little guys at
the same time the mere existence of a
great Council hardly guarantees they'll
all agree on the next leader or that
that leader will agree to be peacefully
outvoted both Robert's rebellion and the
War of the five kings are examples of
what can happen when the Great Houses
are not on the same page about who
should be in power maybe we're all being
pessimists for being skeptical that a
council that convenes every couple
decades might not put a stop to violent
disagreement but it might just make us
realize so it's a coin flip
on whether the new oligarchy will
improve the lives of the small folk even
if it's probably a safe bet that it
won't make their lives any worse now I'm
not saying that game of thrones
necessarily needed an optimistic ending
maybe it was all along a tale about how
humanity's [ __ ] would get them all
killed
or at least living under some new despot
but it's hard to even say if the show
intends this to be an optimistic or
pessimistic ending look no further than
Tyrians first meeting as the newly
instated hand of the king
in its Sam makes some appeals for clean
water Davos requests money to rebuild
the forts and Al Motta bran insists on
building more brothels and Tyrion seems
like he's trudging through the same old
nonsense so much of the show's
definitive meaning is wrapped up in this
scene but it's not even clear if this is
a positive step for the realm or a
negative one it really depends on how
you read it in one reading the small
council is no different than before with
a bickering bureaucracy unable to
determine whether the land needs new
brothels or sewers they're just as
ineffective as ever a couple of visual
metaphors reinforce this reading in one
Tyrion carefully arranges the chairs in
a neat orderly manner as if he's trying
to get it right this time
but when everyone flies in they
immediately disheveled the room so does
this mean that despite Tyrians efforts
everything will remain the same in a
second visual cue the camera widens out
to reveal the map of Westeros fractured
by a crack in the floor is this meant to
suggest that things are still broken the
other way to read this scene is as a
kind of Republican ideal with differing
perspectives coming together to do the
hard work of forging new compromises for
the better of the land
not unlike America's founding fathers
who famously hold themselves up in a hot
sweaty building for months until they
walked out with a constitution so is
this ambiguity in itself deep well if
you ask us this isn't the kind of cool
ambiguity where we ask if Cobb is still
dreaming or not that was the whole point
of the film this is like winging your
high school civics speech on checks and
balances and your classmates walking
away with the impression that you may or
may not really love Stalin but that's
just one message of the show that finds
resolution there's also the much bigger
idea that the show has been dealing with
for all
time that power may inevitably corrupt
those who have it does the finale
gesture toward an end to corrupt
politics or is the new power structure
still susceptible to the problems of the
past what does it mean for brand to be
kinked besides having a story
what sets bran apart in Tyrion speech is
his three-eyed Raven Asst he can warg
into animals and hoe doors and he
contains all the memories of humanity as
bran reminds us when he goes to search
for drogon he can see anything anywhere
perhaps I can find him to carry on with
the rest he's basically a one-man
surveillance state it sucks that Rickon
died but at least now bran gets to be a
big brother again but is this supposed
to be a good thing why does being the
three-eyed raven make bran a good king
when it disqualified him from being Lord
of Winterfell you know our history
better than anyone that'll be useful as
Lord of Winterfell
I'm not Lord of Winterfell I don't
really want any more envy you
you shouldn't envy me mostly I live in
the past I mean sure he didn't want to
be King either but he also travelled a
hell of a long way to accept a position
that had plenty of qualified candidates
and when bran asks why do you think I
came all this way does he mean literally
the journey from Winterfell to King's
Landing or more metaphorically some
far-reaching plot the three-eyed Raven
concocted years ago does living in the
past handing off decisions to the small
Council and playing where in the world
is drogue on San Diego make him the best
choice as many frustrated fans have
pointed out the show doesn't give us a
whole lot of context to understand the
decision we don't know the real
significance of the three-eyed raven why
he's necessary why that position is
compatible with some political titles
but not others really we don't know what
has been going on with brand for a
couple seasons and since the show goes
all-in on brand as the answer to a
decade of political strife that's a
problem since bran doesn't want anymore
that's probably supposed to gesture at
him being incorruptible so if power
corrupts is it deep to say let's give it
to the omniscient wizard man who has no
desires since to the best of my
knowledge aspiring to know everything
isn't practical I'm gonna say no but
wait what if the show is all about how
we should vest power in the people who
know things after all the ones who
really want the best for the people of
Westeros are Varys Tyrion and Sam people
who all eventually came to fear Daenerys
what they have in common they're
interested in evidence-based
decision-making loosely speaking if
anything brands ascension seems to be
saying man if only we could have a state
of technocrats one of whom literally
knows all there is to know then
everything would be fine
and that seems a little too far out of
left field and more like the premise of
a black mirror episode than the end of a
fantasy series so is the wheel broken is
there any meaning to the image of the
throne melting Weiss and Benny off to
answer is part two fantasy if you
haven't checked out our last Game of
Thrones video I'd recommend it while we
were solidly in the wrong about who
would end up on the throne the video
does a great deep dive into the show's
use and subversion of various elements
of the fantasy genre Game of Thrones is
famous for tossing fantasy tropes on
there
head prince charming is a sadistic
monster the good guy protagonist loses
his head in season 1 and the sweet
orphaned princess ends up committing
mass murder but a few of the events in
the final season have us wondering if
they really are subversions or if the
show retreated back to the same old
stereotypes that at once rebelled
against as we mentioned in the last
video george RR martin is both heavily
influenced by and actively subverts the
works of jr. r Toki one token trophy
directly addressed is the idea of good
man equals good king that is if you have
a pure heart he will be a good ruler in
interviews Martin has noted that Tolkien
can say that Aragorn became king and
reigned for a hundred years and he was
wise and good but talking doesn't ask
the question what was aragorn's tax
policy that quote is great it's the
exact sort of interesting political
nuance that we've come to expect from
Game of Thrones which is why it's all
the more frustrating that we could just
change a couple words and make it Weiss
and Benioff can say that bran became
king and reigned for a hundred years and
that he could see things and remember
things but Weiss and Benioff don't ask
the question what was brands tax policy
like we mentioned before maybe the point
is that bran is such an absentee king
than it just doesn't really matter maybe
it's just that he puts capable people in
charge but so did Robert Baratheon maybe
the scene were the small council meet to
talk about the treasury and water supply
is an answer to that question they
really are getting down to the business
of ruling and the success of the kingdom
doesn't rest on brands character long
live bureaucracy but whether this is a
flipped trope or just a regular trope
depends a lot on how we're supposed to
read bran as king and again we just
don't have enough context in the same
interview where he dunked on Aragorn
Martin also may have given us a hint as
to why the great war against the night
king came before the battle for King's
Landing the war that toking wrote about
was a war for the fate of civilization
and the future of humanity and that's
become the template I'm not sure that
it's a good template though the Toki
model led generations of fantasy writers
to produce these endless series of Dark
Lords and their evil minions who are all
very ugly and wear black clothes but the
vast majority of wars throughout history
are
like that evil minions check black
clothes check ugly oh we hate to be
judgey but check with the conflicts
against the white walkers the show is
directly referencing that genre trope
and it's not meant to be subtle so it
makes sense that they positioned this
great war for the future of humanity
before the much more realistic political
war the ultimate showdown of the series
isn't over an existential threat facing
humanity it's over the fate of human
politics as far as Jean rusev versions
go this one seems pretty clear-cut so
deep
maybe but subversion for its own sake
isn't necessarily a good thing and this
still leaves the question why did they
spend so much time building up to the
battle with the night king were they
only using it to show that our anxieties
about a centralized evil are misguided
if that's the case why make a big show
of melting the throne or ditching the
murderous Danny for the uncaring brand
it's possible that the show is making
allegorical references to the wars for
Humanity that have been waged in the
past one of which also heavily
influenced Toki
World War one was far more devastating
than the battle with the night King and
perhaps coincidentally was often
referred to as the Great War but even
after it had ended there wasn't peace
and prosperity throughout the world
certain countries were crippled or blown
to bits in the aftermath of the fighting
led to an even more catastrophic war
world war two World War two is perhaps
even more convincingly described as a
battle for the soul of humanity but
after it was won we got a few decades of
the cold war chaos in the Balkans etc
it's possible that by making these
somewhat jarring choice to move directly
from the great war to the last war Game
of Thrones is acknowledging that wars of
that magnitude leave a power vacuum and
to stabilize a region in a way that can
lead to immediate follow-up conflicts
and so we're left with an ending that
doesn't definitively point to any great
peace nor great strife but to be honest
that doesn't really feel like what
they're doing here the seven kingdoms
were already thoroughly - stabilized
even before the Great War and as far as
the show tells it most of the southern
kingdoms weren't really materially
affected by the battle that they never
participated in it seems like the one
big subversion the writers were
going for was not making John the king
instead they sent him back north of the
wall but choosing brand seems less like
a meaningful subversion and more like
some random decision that's meant to
surprise you so again for its treatment
of the genre that we all thought it was
revolutionising we're gonna say dumb so
what should we make of the Game of
Thrones finale we acknowledge that
writing for television is a hard job
especially when expectations are this
high and when you ran out of rich source
material a few seasons back trying to
complete someone else's story can't be
an easy task but honestly we don't have
a ton of sympathy for Weiss and Benioff
they had access to more money and
brilliant writers than most cable or
network shows could ever dream up and
they still managed to give us an ending
that was both unsatisfying and confusing
there are still plenty of questions that
we can ask about the finale does the
lack of radical political change make a
case for incrementalism over revolution
does the abandonment of the show's
prophecies and end to bloodline
secession signal that nothing is decided
by fate so we have to ask what was Game
of Thrones trying to do what was it all
about
we probably could have answered that
question better at the end of season one
than at the end of season eight D&D took
a show with clear political application
and interesting approach to fantasy and
made it well dumb but hey at least John
got to pet his direwolf and as a dog
lover that means something thanks to all
our patrons who support the channel and
our podcasts be sure to hit that
subscribe button and before you go I
want to remind you to check out this
week's sponsor Skillshare if you love
learning and teaching like we do
Skillshare is a great place to go to
hone your skills they've even got
courses that offer insight on what we do
creating essays for YouTube blogs or any
other outlet a lot of our videos utilize
a million assets pictures and footage
which you can learn more about in
creative video storytelling and editing
making the most of stock footage you can
also learn about optimizing the share
ability of your content with going viral
right to film and make content people
share right now you can get two months
of Skillshare for free by clicking the
link in the description so check out
Skillshare at the link below and start
improving your skills today and as
always thanks for watching guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]